hi Siri is the industrial heart of
central Anatolia a region once afflicted
with extreme poverty the city of 1
million owes its thriving economy
primarily to one family the boy ducks
they started with a carpentry shop and
built up an empire with an annual
turnover of more than 1.5 billion euros
and more than 15,000 employees in
mid-2016 all that came to an end not
because of business problems but
political ones senior family members
were arrested and the factories placed
under state control the boy ducks were
accused of sympathizing with Fethullah
Gulen a preacher of Islam who as
president rich appiah para dhawan claims
instigated the attempted coup in Turkey
now an official administrator overseas
production in the boy duck factories in
kayseri another entrepreneur who did
business with the boy ducks has also
lost everything to the Turkish state my
company had an annual turnover of 2
million euros it was shut down and all
the employees were let go in addition my
personal assets were seized including
our house and my cars I have nothing
left now I live on welfare as an asylum
seeker in Germany he doesn't want to be
recognized because his family is still
in Turkey they aren't allowed to leave
the country in may 2016 the police
searched his offices he's accused of
supporting a terrorist organization to
date over 500 business owners in Turkey
have been expropriated more than 45 in
Caesarea alone there is no parallel in
the history of modern Turkey not even
the local Chamber of Commerce would
respond to our request for an interview
the workers and neighbors of the boy
duck factories won't talk to the cameras
either
many seem afraid they'll be next to be
targeted by the state we have nothing to
do with them goodbye only the newsstand
operator is prepared to speak but with
caution president admits he was deceived
by the Gulen movement that right to make
a mistake should also apply to the boy
doc family we shouldn't forget that boy
doc is not only important for the
economy of Kaiser II but of all Turkey
president air21 seems to rule with an
iron hand in downtown kaziri but
economic consequences are already
looming unemployment is already at a
record high members of the last
remaining opposition party are willing
to give an interview they say the
measures taken against alleged gula and
followers are nothing but a pretext and
pose a grave danger to the country's
economy we all me on all our warnings
have been repeatedly disregarded and now
air dewan's AKP is going after the
property of alleged dual and supporters
and distributing it to their own people
and for years they work together this
man is a living example he was forced
into ruin in Turkey now he's applying
for asylum in Germany he worked side by
side with the AKP stop functionaries for
years nobody cared about his sympathies
with Fatu lagoon now his ex friends see
an opportunity to gain wealth at his
expense his situation is desperate for a
time they imprison my wife trying to
force me to return to Turkey to this day
no official charges have been filed
against me but I'm facing 15 years in
prison and there's no attorney who would
dare to defend me in prison they can do
whatever they want with me so I'm
staying in Germany for now
[Music]
he and thousands more Turkish citizens
see no other choice but to remain in
exile and start from scratch